joining us here on the rich eisen show
another one of our favorites he kicks
off uh this nbc sports on peacock
uh lineup every single day we're on
after dan patrick and he precedes dan
patrick every single day with pro
football talk live and he's got a new
book again coming out in the middle of
march called playmakers you can
pre-order it where all books are sold
right now mike florio back here on the
rich eisen show how are you michael
doing great rich how are you all right
let's just jump right into it as we know
there's always a surprise in uh when
coaches get fired and today's that day
where it happens
with the regular season now on the books
and brian flores and the dolphins is
exactly that surprised what happened
there what gives there well and that is
a stunner and dysfunctional teams do
dysfunctional things look i take it back
to the base level and really you take it
to the top of the organization stephen
ross owner of the team absentee owner
doesn't live doesn't work in south
florida
and doesn't really have his finger on
the pulse of the organization the way he
should and it's a situation that becomes
rife for turf battles
internal struggles
and acrimony between coaching staff and
front office and it sure sounds like
there's a lot of that there they're
putting out the word that brian flores
wasn't
masterful at relationships with people
like gm chris greer or quarterback two
or tonga viola look when you pluck a guy
off of the bill belichick tree you're
not getting him for relationships you're
getting him because he can win football
games and you have to accept the fact
that even if these guys insist they're
not the same as belichick at some
fundamental level they are the same as
belichick because they've seen how he
conducts business and that's the problem
if you don't win early then you need to
worry about whether or not somebody is
conspiring to get you out of there or
the people that you're making upset
because you're trying to do things in a
belichickian way
are
fed up and they want to move on and i
just feel like something like that has
trickled into this that brian flores
isn't a guy who's going to play the
political game he's just trying to win
football games and meanwhile
other forces in the organization bring
him down and make the case to stephen
ross as they whisper in his ear
in the luxury suite while flores is
coaching the team that this guy needs to
go that this is all his fault i i think
there's plenty of blame to go around but
i think most people would say brian
flores given that he didn't have the
the best players by far of his peers
he's done pretty well with what he's had
so that made it very surprising there's
always more to the story behind the
scenes but i just feel like that entire
setup where ross is just a
fly-in for the games and go back to new
york type of an owner it it's it's not
an ideal way by far to run an nfo
organization well he knows enough that
he says it's not about tua uh or deshawn
watson um and
so what
how does the quarterback situation play
into what happened and what happens next
do you think i'm told that flores didn't
want deshawn that it was all one big
distraction from what they were trying
to do and look at what happened when the
trade deadline came and went that's when
they started winning football games
because ross wanted the sean ross wanted
joe burrow the bengals wouldn't trade
down from the top spot a couple of years
ago then ross wanted to he got to it
then ross wanted to sean and he's going
to keep pushing for deshawn watson i'll
see why he would change his mind what
did we see from tua over the balance of
the season that makes us think he's a
potential franchise quarterback they're
desperate to get another dan marino or
someone who is in that same category as
among the best quarterbacks in football
and and ross barn storms in
says what he'd like to have happen
pushes for certain things but he's not
there grinding away every single day
with everyone else so none of it
surprises me
and
i i really don't think this means that
tua wins and he's the guy moving forward
i still think ross is going to push for
deshaun watson or someone else if he
thinks there's some other alternative to
tour that's out there that can help him
get the dolphins to where he wants them
to be so are you saying your best your
knowledge and and uh and insight into
this is that ross is a
flying game day fly out guy but then
flies in figuratively to make such a
crucial mandate as to who the
quarterback is and who they're drafting
is that it's not a mandate see one of
the
privileges of being a billionaire is you
never have to
give orders you don't have to well you
just you there's a way you make your
preferences known and the people who are
working for you who
hope to continue working for you we'll
be paying attention to what the boss
likes it's like to stand in the calzone
when steinbrenner wants a calzone
because stanza's getting them a calzone
every single day until
steinbrenner decides you like something
else i mean that that's
that's
what most owners will do so then they
can say oh no i'm not involved i don't i
don't tell my people what to do
no you don't tell them what to do but
you make it clear what you would like
them to do and if they're smart they'll
do it
and i i guess is that why grier stays
because the the the conversation of of
two over herbert
is one that uh still resonates today
even though both are out of the playoffs
again
you know so crews got the cover you know
along the lines of hey you know i didn't
want to you're the one that wanted him
boss uh i mean it's always an awkward
conversation to have
but i i'm always i'm always
troubled when one goes and one stays
regardless of whether it's gm goes and
coach stays or coach goes and gm stays i
believe there should be equal
accountability in a football operation
and any time one survives and one goes
especially when you look at the team and
say they're really not in that category
of teams that we think are
kind of lost their way and need a reset
anytime one stays and one goes it's a
sign of dysfunction it's a sign of a
power struggle and it's a sign that
there are different standards of
accountability being applied when
everyone should be under the same
mandate we all survive and thrive or we
all fail because if you if you know
there's a path to
i can save my ass and i can blame it on
someone else what happens when adversity
strikes people start blaming someone
else in order to cover their own butts
and when the owner's not there every
single day it's easier to pull that off
mike florio pro football talk here on
the rich eisen show you just said that
you don't like it when a general manager
stays and a coach goes or vice versa
well as we are currently chatting uh
here after one o'clock eastern on the
monday after the regular season dave
gettleman has announced his retirement
it's official he's out as the general
manager of the giants but joe judge
is still there what can you tell us
about what the giant's plans are in this
position ownership likes joe judge and
ownership would like to find a way to
keep joe judge for a variety of reasons
beyond the fact that they like him
they've had ben mcadoo two years and out
he actually made it up until the last
game of his second year then pat shurmur
two years in out they understand what a
bad look it is for them to go three
straight coaches two years and now they
want to keep joe judge if they can the
locker room i'm told is divided on judge
and we've we've seen
the antics over the past week or so
which have made no sense it's like he
was trying to talk his way out of a job
with the things he said and the decision
he made yesterday to do the quarterback
sneak on third and none have you ever
seen that mike
still goofy have you ever seen that
before i i mean that that's not a
professional football move that that's
kind of like you know i'll be honest
that's pop warner stuff you know i mean
i don't even know what pop warner team
would do something like that where you
just usually meaning this game it's more
of a like if you're playing for
something
and it's a windy day or something like
that or there's some you know or your
punters injured i mean there's there's a
set of circumstances where
it makes sense
to just get the ball farther away from
the goal line but it's not like they
were on the one yard line
and and it just it just seems odd when
you're in a game that has no stakes
whatsoever why are you doing that and so
yeah i it it was unprecedented and it's
almost like he's trying to get fired at
this point but my understanding is what
the giants hope to do is hire gm and let
the gm make the decision on who the
coach will be but in the hiring of the
gm we'll have a pretty good idea of what
the gm's going to do
exactly i don't understand kevin abrams
he's keeping joe judge if they bring
somebody from the patriots he's keeping
joe judge if they bring somebody in who
doesn't know joe judge from adam then
it's probably not going to be joe judge
you know these general managers show up
with a short list of coaches that they
would hire if they ever get the chance
compiled based on 20 30 years of
experience and if joe judge's name isn't
on that list then you know maybe they
kick the can for one year i don't know
uh but but it sure sounds like ownership
wants to continue to to hide in the
background and let others
take the public criticism for the
current state of the team i don't know
if you saw again i i don't see it live
obviously because i'm competing against
them but i did see on twitter michael
strahan's reaction when glazer mentioned
abrams is the possibility of being the
general manager at joe judges you know
behest and he just screamed oh no that's
what he's i don't know if you saw that
you should see i did i did i mean so
he's like oh no and then basically said
the giant should just go outside the
organization and start from scratch
stray said that which is quite something
my theory on giants ownership is is
pretty simple
there isn't much of a difference between
the maras and the joneses the difference
is the joneses have no qualms about
attaching their names faces and voices
to the fact that they're making their
decisions now the joneses don't have to
deal with the back pages of the tabloids
i think the mirrors would rather their
gm their coach be the one that gets
caricatured on the back page and they
always
find a way to stay out of the fight now
just don't show up at any events and
speak and you won't get booed but
otherwise the coach and the gm get the
focus and the mirrors are
you've got john who's a very active
owner you've got his brother chris who's
the head of personnel they've got a
nephew who's who's involved in this and
i understand these are family businesses
but at a certain point it's a
multi-billion dollar football operation
and you need to entrust it to the
professionals not just do it because hey
we own the team and it's fun and we
think we know what we're doing look at
what's happened ten years for the giants
one playoff appearance no postseason
wins since super bowl 46 i'm amazed in
hindsight that they won super bowl 42 in
super bowl 46 given the way the team has
been run over the past decade mike
florio pro football talk here on the
rich eisen show i'll give you a choice
here mike here's a little sports talk
radio conversation for you so you got in
denver you got a situation where a
general manager's there and there's no
quarterback of the future unless you
really believe in drew lock you could
turn something around in minnesota you
got no general manager
at all
and you've got a quarterback who's got
an you know who's paid like he's garrett
cole but only one more year left on that
contract and he really hasn't won very
much and then you got chicago where you
got your your future quarterback already
drafted and ownership expecting you to
turn whatever's right there into gold if
you consider
you know um justin field's straw which
is the best job do you think for a coach
in the nfl mike florio well
they're all open for a reason so none of
them are great at this point and
denver's ownership might change too how
about that ownership will change it will
change i'll be shocked at this point if
ownership remains in the bowling family
i think the team's going to get sold now
george payton is entrenched but how
entrenched are you if new owner comes in
and says i'm up you know i'm a
multi-billionaire i'll write your buy
out and and uh here's your check and
we'll go get somebody else um in in
chicago i want to know what ted phillips
role is going forward is he still in
charge of the football operation he's
been the president since 1999 they have
three
uh postseason
victories
in 22 years of ted phillips being in
charge of the football operation so is
he going to be neutralized is there
somebody else there in minnesota i'd be
more comfortable if the wilfs
were not absentee owners like steven
ross but they have first class stadium
first class practice facility commitment
to spending money
it's just a matter of them getting the
right people in place and without
ownership there i think they need a
strong person who runs the team day in
and day out and acts like the surrogate
owner i'm not saying you should be a
former coach because coaches are good at
coaching they're not very good at being
anything but coaches but they need
somebody to run that building whether
it's the gm whether it's a vp of
football operations
and be that presence every day
but they've been i mean look rick
spielman was there 16 years mike zimmer
was there eight years even though
they're not showing up every day at the
facility they let their guys do their
thing and so of those three
uh to me when you consider all factors
i'd say that it's got the potential
because kirk cousins you can unload him
on somebody somebody somebody will take
him on i don't know whether you have to
pay part of the salary or or do whatever
but it's only 35 million the market's
now 45 million and maybe you find some i
don't know i don't i really don't know
who you find
uh to take cousins for one more year and
i know cousins wants to stay in
minnesota but he's got real limitations
he'll generate some great stats but when
the play that's called falls apart he he
can't improvise and and that that
usually ends up being the ceiling on
what that offense can do but you already
you also have jefferson there and cook
so which one would you choose mike i
know
oh right now the minnesota job would be
the top for me i'd go minnesota then
denver then chicago because chicago as
long as ted phillips is there i i don't
want anything to do with chicago how
about that and so what about um
a couple more minutes left with mike
florio did uh rich basaccio save his and
maybe mayhawk's job because if i'm mark
davis i'm looking around in this
beautiful stadium there in vegas
you know with uh madden's
uh you know wife just lit the figurative
lamp there and the place is going nuts
right and and it's las vegas nevada and
i've got the hottest game in town
and they just won a playoff game and my
guy's pushing buttons like versace and
mayok's you know draft choices some of
them are just stellar jacobs you know
crosby
renfro um what do you think do you stick
with it golic and i were talking about
this earlier and he made a great point
sometimes the answer is right in front
of your face
and when you consider the impact that
their achievement of a playoff birth
after everything they went through the
departure of john gruden the henry ruggs
tragedy the ups the downs the highs the
lows the blowout loss to the chiefs that
was the low water mark and then they win
four in a row and they fight in scratch
and claw and they face an unprecedented
situation literally unprecedented i
don't like to over hype things because
it's what we do i think the passage of
time will make what happened last night
seem bigger
not lesser i agree to have three teams
fate tied to one game one 10-minute
overtime period and all the machinations
and all the possibilities of what could
be done and
i i i don't know how you after what's
happened to get to the playoffs
regardless of whether or not they beat
the bengals on saturday i don't know how
you don't make rich versace the coach
now and i've come a long way in 24 hours
but you mentioned the vikings and the
whole kirk cousins thing i think back to
what the vikings did in 2017 sam
bradford gets hurt case keenum comes in
they go 13-3 they get to the brink of
the super bowl and then they throw case
keenum out the door and they pay all
that money to kirk cousins he goes to
the playoffs once in four years like
golic said sometimes the answer is
staring you in the face i thought at the
time the vikings should have kept keenum
i think the raiders should keep versace
and you know if it doesn't work then
you'll know that in a couple of years
but how do you turn your back
on
on this lightning in a bottle that
they've engineered in las vegas i you
can't you can't and whoever comes in to
try to follow that act is going to be
operating with one hand tied behind his
back because everybody's going to be
saying well they should have just kept
versace if the new coach has any
struggles whatsoever well looks like
that new coach if it would be would be
uh would be harbaugh would be my college
coach right
who by the way his defensive coordinator
and those championship years in san
francisco and stanford just got fired by
denver so you know maybe that's what
mark davis is thinking about i i i don't
know look that the buzz rich had been
building and it was getting stronger and
stronger jim harbaugh to the raiders jim
harbaugh to the raiders
now what i'm hearing is that
he's he's playing the game and and
god bless him when you get leverage
whatever profession you're in go out and
use it get your money he cut his salary
in half last year when things weren't
going well now things are going well
there's nfl interest take that and turn
it into a better contract when you
perform you get paid and i won't be
surprised if he ends up with a new
contract and staying put at michigan
especially since it's going to be very
difficult now to follow rich basatia
into the uh the raiders coaching job and
and i you know i don't know would the
bears be interested would any of these
teams be interested why wouldn't you be
it was 44 19 and one right in four years
with the 49ers but uh
um
it's it's definitely something that that
folks need to seriously consider you can
be a tough guy to get along with but you
know what most successful coaches are
tough guys to get along mike thanks for
the time really appreciate it as always
let's uh let's stay in touch you know
i'll be always reaching out to you
thanks anytime rich take care you got
that's mike florio catches shows
here on nbc sports on peacock and follow
him at pro football talk i follow him
you should
as well
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here